all right hello
everybody
welcome welcome as we are letting
everybody into the room i hope you are
all having a fabulous friday
it is absolutely beautiful
and wonderful day no matter where you
are you have the opportunity to make it
wonderful
so our mindset and our choices and the
things that we do
are actually it's the way that we react
to others that can absolutely change the
way that our days go so i just want to
welcome you to ask doc live
my name is rebecca dukes kozak and i
will be your host for the next two hours
of this awesome show that it is my
absolute privilege to be able to host
and bring to you each and every week
now this program is sponsored by
askdoclive.com
but i
really encourage you
that if somebody invited you to watch
this program whether you're here live
with us
or you're watching the replay
make sure that you get back with the
person that invited you to watch this
program okay
they have a vested interest in making
sure that you get what you need in order
to reach optimal health
they care
make sure that you get back with them
and thank them for caring
now if you have never spoken to anybody
about anything that you hear today
on this program
we do have a website askdoclive.com
that has a contact us
that you can send an email and reach out
to us one of our certified holistic
health coaches will get back to you and
insisting
in assisting you in getting the products
that you need specific to your needs
i just have to thank my co-hosts because
they do an amazing job if you're on live
with us make sure that you have that
chat
box open because they are putting
information that will assist you in
being able to get information and extra
little resources to help you reach your
goals
nasimah omar ruth ellen sanchez dr judy
reynolds and heather bowen are
absolutely
amazing
at helping us keep this show running if
you have your camera on
please make sure that anything
that is going on in the camera view
is family appropriate so i hate to have
to say that but we love you guys and we
just want to make sure that it's a safe
environment for everybody
and also if you would like to ask a
question find that raised hand option
click on participants and under
participants there's the raise hand or
depending on what system you're using
there's something that says reactions
click on reactions you can raise your
hand there also
now the content of this program
is to provide educational information
only on nutrition this program is not
meant to take the place of your primary
care physician and the fda requires us
to let you know that our products are
not meant to treat prevent diagnose or
cure any disease
now we are absolutely
honored
to be able to have
somebody that has proven through science
that
there are no genetically
transmitted diseases folks
the study of epigenetics proves that
what we do
around us what we put in our bodies
affects the way that our genes are
expressed
we have a nutrient
deprived body our genes are not going to
express in a way that we ultimately
if you want good health
want them to be expressed
it's just it's amazing
i didn't believe it myself
until i actually
started on the products and felt the
difference
and to bring us information about this
amazing science of epigenetics
we have
the one the only one of the co-founders
of epigenetics dr joel wallach dr
wallach
welcome to ask doc live
well thank you so much for the kind
introduction rebecca and your whole team
thank you everybody for being here
and um
i i just get breathless thinking how
many people we're going to help today
and i do want to start off by talking
about obesity because it's really
starting to warm up and people are
taking their sweatshirts off and
standing in front of the mirror and
saying oh i'm about 25 to 50 pounds
overweight here i ate too many waffles
during the winter time and so i need to
do something so we're going to talk
about obesity a little bit
and so i went and looked it up the
record for the weight
uh top weight
uh when it came to women is 1 200 pounds
the
top record for men is 1
400 pounds
okay now there's not many people that
reach that but those are the the records
okay that uh you just ask siri and syria
will come up with those numbers and of
course there's some changes not even
numbers it's a little bit of change in
addition to the big numbers
but
obesity uh people really have a
misconception about it uh they think
well it's because i'm just eating too
much fat
no it has nothing to do with that that's
absolutely nothing to do with that
when a person is
two pounds overweight 25 pounds
overweight 50 pounds overweight 100
pounds overweight or so or more
it's because they're missing some
nutrients and the body's looking for
those nutrients the body keeps kicking
you and saying eat keep find that
nutrient keep eat find that nutrient eat
fight that nutrient and that's the
problem
and that's why people just say i don't
know why i'm hungry i just ate
3 000 calorie lunch here
why am i still hungry well you got
plenty of calories in that 3 000 calorie
month so why are you still hungry you're
hungry because your body's telling you
look you need these nutrients keep
eating until you find them okay that's
why you just see people i don't know why
but i just eat all day i can't stop
eating well that's because your body is
telling you to look for those nutrients
and so this is why
now the only reason but it's one of the
reasons why we really really understood
how to
help people
prevent getting overweight and how to
lose excess weight very economically and
you know without surgery and all that
kind of stuff
and um and and you'll add 25 to 50
healthier life because
again
um being overweight being obese is a
nutritional deficiency
all right it's it's not a calorie issue
it's a nutritional deficiency
and um we've worked it out to where we
have what we call a keto
shake
the shake comes in strawberry or or
chocolate
and during the week i like you know when
they're working or going to school i
want to have one meal a day doesn't have
to be the same meal it's a meal replacer
it's not
to take with a meal it's a meal replacer
and based on your schedule you can
choose whatever meal you want on that
particular day to use that keto shake
and then have say
depending on your body weight one two or
three of the rebound or sports drink and
we have those the cans back in and
that's really exciting people are just
going by and by the case and buying
about the case and so forth because our
sports drink has 100 nutrients in it
78 minerals
and 25 vitamins and
amino acids okay
and so
we're looking at a totally different
concept here
and you take these nutrients and
suddenly now your appetite disappears
you say i don't know i didn't finish my
plate
okay and you're just having one meal a
day that's replaced um
by a keto shake now on the weekends when
you don't have anything scheduled
okay and somebody else is gonna drive
and all that kind of stuff
you might try one day whether it's the
saturday or the sunday
have two meals two keto shake meals and
one day a week either on a saturday or
sunday or whatever day you have off
during the week okay
and then you'll kind of say okay okay
um i'm losing weight a little bit faster
here because it's not a calorie issue
it's a nutritional deficiency issue why
people become obese
and
we deal with literally thousands of
people every day who want to lose weight
and
we've been extremely successful
because we know the basic underlying
cause and so that's why we have such
success
and then also going along with obesity
it's very common to have high blood
pressure and diabetes both of those
are nutritional deficiencies diseases
neither of them
are
autoimmune diseases neither of them are
genetic diseases
very simple if you're on medication for
high blood pressure don't cold turkey
off the medication but you had our
two your healthy brain heart pack the
big hammer the healthy brain heart pack
215 nutrients including the 90 which
everybody agrees upon as being
um
the you know basic essentials
we have 215 nutrients in the basic
healthy brain heart pack
one per hundred pounds of body weight
and then you throw in the msm
three
for breakfast three for lunch free for
dinner time that'll be two bottles a
month of the msm to help rebuild uh
currently is ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between a
vertebrae bone makes the mold itself
and you want to be
rebuilding the bone matrix in the bone
marrow is very important because that's
your immune system
okay you cannot make red blood cells you
cannot make white blood cells you cannot
make platelets you cannot make
antibodies without your bone marrow
being healthy so you need that msm you
need our collagen peptides take a scoop
of that
in your morning drink take a scoop and
then your evening drink don't forget the
vitamin d three three of those twice a
day because most people who are adults
sit in the shade even in sunny places
they don't get down to their bathing
suit bikini
and lay out in the sun for a couple
hours they just don't do it they sit in
their shade and let the kids lay out in
the sun okay it's kind of interesting
and so that's kind of what's going on
there and then diabetes is the same
thing diabetes oftentimes goes along
with
um obesity
and again diabetes is not a genetic
disease so
diabetes is not an autoimmune disease
diabetes
is very simple nutritional deficiencies
and we have a program for that too
okay
it's called um and see here the healthy
blood sugar pack
okay but if you're taking two health
abandoned heart packs you don't need to
do that you just take the sweeties which
is the key part of the formula for the
healthy blood sugar pack the sweeties i
get to two bottles of them so you can
take three twice a day
okay if you weigh 200 plus pounds i
would get three three times a day it'll
be two bowels three bottles a month so
the sweeties don't cold turkey off your
medication just like with the high blood
pressure medication but as your blood
sugar begins to drop you can slowly
reduce the medication for diabetes based
on the numbers usually within two to six
weeks you'll be off the medication and
you're losing a half a pound of two
pounds a day that's the usual schedule
for people when they get on our um keto
shake and get off all the bad foods you
know the fried foods and the processed
meats and the oils and the glutens and
the wheat brown rhinos and the sugar and
the carbonated drinks
you will lose a half a pound of two
pounds a day so if you need to lose
25 pounds you could do that really
easily within two months or three months
very comfortably
and so how long do you have to stay on
these all these nutrients well forever
how long you need oxygen forever how
long you need water forever
don't go off these nutrients or don't
cut them in half
because what will happen here is
you'll start having problems again
within a month or two and you say well i
tried that and it didn't work well it
did work but you stopped taking it
okay you don't put dirt from texas or
saudi arabia in your car
okay you put oil in it okay you got to
do the same thing when it comes to
yourself treat yourself as well as you
treat your car
okay
and so we can eliminate obesity in
america but everybody's just got to get
on the same
uh
horse if you will
and it'll be easy now one of the things
that goes along with
osteoporosis which is
excuse me obesity which is a nutritional
deficiency is osteoporosis because it's
also a nutritional deficiency disease
and people get fractures they say well i
just weighed too much i broke my leg
well that's just not happening that way
and um you get edema and swelling in the
legs
and you get pain in the joints and you
get tremors and you get ringing in the
ears because you have osteoporosis of
the skull and you get gastroparesis
terrible pain in your stomach your
doctors think you have
ulcers
and they want to take out half your
stomach
they'll want to take out your
gallbladder
they will
want to
um
you know
take out
just about everything they can
because that's how they get the money to
send their kids to college okay
and so you have to be up on this and and
so
osteoporosis is actually quite easy
that's it it's actually quite an
expensive disease because so many people
have it
and you know doctors say well you're
getting older you know you got to expect
this and you know we can give you some
pain relief we can give you this we can
give you that but the osteoporosis keeps
going on
and they milk the population like a
dairy herd okay and so it's one of those
deals or
um
osteoporosis on the skull you get the
clues of course we have the book it's uh
all in your head
okay and rebecca and i are working on
finishing up a cd that goes along with
this now
most of our books we have cds you go
along with them well we finally got one
that rebecca and i made um
when uh all in your head and it goes
into the 25 different diseases that we
know of that are caused by osteoporosis
skull including afib doctors think
that's a heart issue so they anesthetize
you cut you open take your heart out put
a hot branding iron all over trying to
make it beat regularly instead of
irregularly
because really just the obviously
approach to the skull is squeezing the
tenth crayon nerve which controls the
right rhythm of the heart
and so once you read this book you'll
just say oh my gosh oh my gosh i had two
people in my family die from that
afib
okay during the ablation procedure which
is one of the most highly deadly medical
therapies there there is
okay is ablation because doctors
mistakenly think
that afib is due to a heart problem no
it's due to osteoporosis skull
okay so all these things really really
really begin to
add up and build up
and
these are things that you can deal with
you can reverse all this you go to the
doctor say hey i want you to check out
my heartbeat i think everything's cool
here and they'll say oh okay um let's
have you come back in two weeks let's
see if it's still going that way that it
is you say you do anything different and
you might tell them but they're not
going to believe it okay
um but they're just not wanting you to
sit in the waiting room and talk to
other patients in the waiting room i
find that interesting and so
osteoporosis
occurs when you have osteoporosis in
your right knee you have it in every
bone in your body if you have
osteoporosis in your jaw
or your tmj joint you know your temporal
mandibular joint you have osteoporosis
in every joint and every bone in your
body and of course there's symptoms of
that you get anemia because your bone
marrow is dead we have osteoporosis and
you cannot make red blood cells you're
you're susceptible more susceptible even
if you had a vaccination you're more
susceptible to
infections of viruses bacteria fungus
and yeast because your immune system is
dead when you have osteoporosis
of the skull and the other bones in your
body because you can't make white blood
cells red blood cells platelets and
antibodies and so forth
so once you understand that basic
principles
you'll say oh this is this osteoporosis
is going to go away all this obesity is
going to go away and it will
we do this thousands of times a day
maybe if you count it practically is if
we do it thousands of times an hour
around the world
okay with all that said i'm going to
turn it back over to rebecca here
because she has
a lot going on that we need to deal with
dr wallach there's a lot of people going
that have things going on that
they can deal with
intentionally
and being able to choose a better health
journey and dr wallach i'm so thankful
that i found you
because my health journey was going
downhill fast
and now i feel absolutely fabulous
and i have you to think
well you have done a great job
and tell people how much weight you've
lost
i have lost 100 pounds and it's not the
same 25 pounds five times
i've had a lot of people say you know
i've lost a lot of weight too but it's
the same 10 pounds over and over again
or the same
you know i lose 50 pounds i gained back
60.
that has not been my case i have been
able to lose the weight
and keep it off because my body is not
in that starvation mode as you had
mentioned
it's absolutely incredible and
you know that first two months i wasn't
even thinking about weight
yeah i was almost 270 pounds
but the fact that i couldn't roll myself
out of bed and i was in so much pain and
i didn't know when i did get out of bed
if i was gonna hit the floor because of
the pain or not
that was what was my main concern
and then whenever i stepped on the scale
at the three month mark because i knew
my clothes were getting smaller
i mean bigger
and i saw that i was down 20 pounds i'm
like
wow
i didn't i wasn't even trying
but i was given my body what it had been
starving for dr wallach
and then he kept looking kept looking
then we gotta find it keep eating
something until you find it well and and
you are absolutely right with that
because i
could eat with the best of them
i mean i would i and i remember even in
high school
i managed the football team and we'd go
out to eat and i was able to keep up
with the biggest eater
i wasn't gaining weight at that time i
didn't have any weight issues until
after i got pregnant with my fourth son
but
i
i never felt satisfied
when it came to food
i would feel stuffed but not satisfied
and now
i can eat a little bit i'm satisfied i
don't
crave i don't have all those munchies
all day long like i did before
not for salty stuff not for sweet stuff
i absolutely love it
so i'm still on that journey
to reach to reach my optimal goal but
my
my my saying is progress over perfection
and that's that's one of my
one of my businesses is project or
progress over perfection health coaching
so
everybody life
is
as long as you're making progress in the
right direction
that's the important part
well we give you a triple a plus so you
have been really such a fantastic leader
for so many literally i would say at
least
tens of thousands of people maybe more
than that
through askdoc live and we can't thank
you enough for all that you and your
team does
uh because
um
somebody has got to save america it's
not going to be the politicians in
washington
that's that's absolutely right and i am
so thankful for my team
uh jonty mccollier who does all the
technical stuff and gets it loaded on
the internet so that we have that
option to be able to share it with
others through our youtube channel
through our facebook channels
through our website he does all that
background stuff um which i'm so
thankful for he's like
johnny on the spot
um and then
ruth allen and nasima and dr judy and
heather
i mean
i i couldn't do this without them they
are amazing and and so are you dr wally
none of us would be here without you so
well we're family we're family family
we are family and dr wallach we have
some family members who have their hands
up okay
now i just want to remind everybody if
you're on live with us you have the
opportunity to raise your hand and ask
dr wallach cool your question live
just go to that function of either
reactions or participants and find that
raised hand option
so let's go to the first hand that is up
and it looks like linda b
linda go ahead and unmute yourself
you're online with dr wallach good
morning
hi good morning
good morning
i've been on this meeting before in the
past and
i
i wondered how
how did you
off
truly
find out if you do have osteoporosis of
the skull is there a test
x-ray or mri work okay
yeah there's two ways you can do it
number one
both ways you need to get a hold of the
book it's all in your head it goes into
the 25 different diseases that people
can get
any one or five or 10 or 20 or all 25 of
them okay when you have obviously
approach to the skull
and of course if you have any of those
it tells you right away you have
osteoporosis you don't need to do any
other tests you know you have tinnitus
you have ringing in the ears any buzzing
or ringing ears you're shaking your head
yes that means you have osteoporosis no
i don't but i have a friend who does and
uh for me it's it's my heart okay if you
have afib asian fibrillation irregular
heartbeat there could be a slow heart
rate which is bradycardia
it could be a fast heart rate could be a
tachycardia it could be an irregular
heart rate afib
all of those are caused by um
osteoporosis to the skull
but if you want to test they can do a
scan i don't like x-rays or radiation
but you can do a non-radiation scan of
the of the skull
it should only be a quarter of an inch
thick but if it's an inch thick you got
osteoporosis to the skull
okay because all the connective tissue
builds up
uh were should be you know a quadrantic
bone now it's a one inch or two inch
thick
uh connective tissue like tendon
okay and because of that is squeezing
the nerves
the 12 pairs of cranial nerves and
squeezing the spinal cord and creating
all those symptoms
got it
yes if you have dental problems if you
have receding gums and bleeding gums
your teeth are all loose and when you're
12 years old 15 years old you had to go
to an orthodontist to have braces put on
you know osteoporosis of the skull
babies are born with osteoporosis called
it's not just an aging thing babies are
born with it's called herbs palsy they
have osteoporosis skulls squeezing the
spinal cord so they're paralyzed from
the neck down when they're born
and doctors think it's um you know
something
like a cerebral palsy but really it's
obviously approached to the skull okay
um
called herbs palsy
and so you get them on the nutrients and
within a couple of weeks they don't have
it anymore you don't get them on the
nutrients you know they can go into you
know five six seven eight years old as
they're not getting the nutrients it's
not going to go away
all right
okay
so those are those are the ways and so
you um you know you look at the book and
say god do i have any of these 25
diseases
okay then you know you have osteoporosis
skull
i am taking a calcium supplement
now it's called algaecal
and then i take strontium in the evening
okay
stop
stop stop
really stop
okay now listen to me
okay okay
you have to appreciate
that just taking those weird things
you're taking
isn't going to solve your problem
okay i can tell because you have gray
hair gray hair has nothing to do with
aging it's a nutritional deficiency
and one of those nutritional
deficiencies it causes great hair causes
osteoporosis the skull
uh-huh uh-huh uh-huh you take all this
where yeah i'm taking more calcium i'm
taking more calcium well that's not the
total answer
that's like your car
do you just put water in the radiator
no you have to put antifreeze in with it
and then you have to have your
windshield wiper fluid then you have to
have your oil you have to have the
gasoline you have to have the heavy
grease
okay for your oil pan
and all of these
things going on in there
okay and so it's a lot more complicated
just taking some extra calcium and some
weird mineral okay
so don't don't go there because you're
wasting your money you're not going to
get what you're looking for
okay
and as far as breakfast if i can't have
toast or any of that the wheat in the
room okay i missed the first part of
that it says as far as what well what
what can i eat for breakfast if i can't
have the weed or i can't have my beloved
bread in the morning and
okay well
what i had for breakfast this morning
was you know two scoops of rice steamed
okay i had um two eggs
with soft yolks
okay okay i had grapes
okay
and i i had um what we call chicken of
the sea you know tuna
yeah
you could have a hamburger you could
have a piece of steak some morning to
have a steak along with everything else
you eat like an asian
eat rice do not eat wheat brother oats
anymore
okay because when you look at the
countries that have the worst problem
with obesity and the worst problem with
osteoporosis skull
is europe
you know england uk
uh italy
spain ireland
sweden denmark all those places and then
america and canada
okay asia doesn't have
the problems we have they are the
longest lived people
when you look at the life expectancy
which is a way of measuring
success okay
um let's see here life expectancy i know
it's in the pile here it is okay
um
we were on with the philippines last
night their life expectancy is 71.
that's because they have a lot of
military bases from europe the united
states
and um they all began to eat wheat
just like all our military people did
they stopped eating rice and went to
wheat
okay then the usa our life expectancy
75.
um
australia it's 82.9
let's see here new zealand is 82.3 japan
is 84.7
um china is 76 because they have places
where they grow a lot of wheat
the uk is 81.
russia is 72 because they grow a lot of
wheat south africa is 63.
mexico's 77.
and the people who live the longest
okay and i should say germany their
their life expectancy is 81.26
um spain is 82. but the ones who live
the longest live up in the himalayan
mountains they have all those volcanoes
and the volcanic ash gets into their
fields and so when they grow their
potatoes and their corn and all that
kind of stuff and they don't grow wheat
their life expectancy is 120.
is 120 better than 75.
now we're supposed to have the best
health care system in the world i just
ask any doctor that will tell you that
they'll stand up on top of their
hospital and beat their chest and say we
have the best health care system in the
world and then they bill you three times
okay yeah and we don't have the best
health care system in the world we have
the most expensive health care system in
the world you can't escape equate
expense with best okay
yeah so what is it that these people in
hanzo do well did you ever hear that
book or the movie lost horizon written
by james
hilton
no
okay yeah lost horizon uh the book came
out first and i think it was like 1934
or something like that
because he
followed
one of these people from china who is in
the him lands as a doctor
and
he's taking all these people who are 100
years old 110 years old and they
couldn't believe it so this james hilton
was a big um
investigative reporter for the new york
times so he goes and spends a year
following this chinese doctor and
visiting all these people who had
records to show that they were 110 years
old 108 years old and so forth
and so he wrote the book lost horizon
and then a couple years later the movie
came out with the same title lost
verizon everybody needs to read that
book everybody needs to see that movie
because it's a true story
of one
culture
okay and if we eat like them we avoid
the things they avoid
okay you'll add 25 to 50 healthy years
your life okay
okay
all right thank you very much you bet
all right thank you linda
so i
i there's another linda that had a
question in the chat and i really hope
that she was listening because her
question was in regards to osteoporosis
of the hips
so if you've got osteoporosis in one
area of your body the chances are that's
that's only where you're getting the
symptoms right dr wallach
yeah
osteoporosis is not just a
disease of an isolated joint no when you
have it as you as you point out rebecca
when you point out that if you have
osteoporosis in one hip you got it in
every joint every bone in your body and
the reason why it's in the right hip is
probably a truck driver who has all of
the clutch and the gas and the brakes
and everything for a big semi truck with
that right side and so the right hip is
showing a little more wear and tear than
say his um
uh neck vertebrae okay but he still has
osteoporosis there but it's not going to
uh have a severe symptoms is that right
hip because as for all his work is going
on with that right leg for the brakes
and the gas pedal and the um
clutch and that kind of stuff okay
absolutely
you know it really amazes me and
i was talking about with this with some
of my teammates um
that there are so many people that
are suffering
and
they're suffering from things that i
suffered from dr wallach
and as i've been listening to you over
the past two years now
all of my symptoms almost all of my
symptoms were because of
osteoporosis
whether it was of the skull the back the
joints
everywhere
did they improve
they're gone
[Laughter]
yes they improved they've improved
um and my symptoms dr wildlife started
when i was eight years old that i can
remember
because that's when i had my first
migraine that put me in the hospital
yeah that's the fifth cranial nerve the
trigeminal nerve
okay and you get headaches behind the
eyes and your cheeks and your temples
and so forth
and that's a classic trigeminal
neuralgia
yeah it was horrific to the point where
i still remember it and
lived with it almost every single day
for
35 years
well what happened to the doctors did
you complain to the doctors about it
oh they wanted to put me on more
chemical drugs
and therapies and
everything that i tried nothing helped
and so i
just figured i had to live with it
and fortunately
i don't live with it anymore so they
were wrong
you were right
i'll accept it i love it
um and i love the fact that so many more
people are finding
relief also dr wallach
yeah we can't thank you enough for
sharing your story because a lot of
people are you know they're shy and they
don't want to share their story but
you've shared your story
and literally over time here uh because
of stock live the program you've created
uh there's thousands of people listen
every friday
and then of course say during the week
this is recorded and posted so everybody
can watch it 10 times a day if they want
to
okay
that's right we make this resource
available to everybody to be able to
share and make sure that this
information
is heard
because you're not going to hear it
anywhere else
and
it's so vitally important and i hear so
many people that say oh i'm not gluten
intolerance or oh i don't have celiac
disease i was one of them
and when i cut the gluten
i started feeling better when i went
totally gluten free without
contamination
i feel absolutely fabulous
absolutely fabulous in a very short
amount of time
so it is possible and most of all it's
worth it i don't even miss those other
things there's so many different
alternatives dr wallach
that there's no reason for you to
feel
that you're deprived
and
that deprivation
is all up here
it's all in your head
ah that would be a good title for a book
hey
i think i'll record a message on that
book too
well dr wallach let's go to our next
hand that is up and vaughn
go ahead and unmute yourself
good morning
you're on live with dr wallick
oh wait a minute try to unmute again my
dear
oh no
say something i see you're unmuted but i
don't see that
i can't hear you my dear
we'll work on that
so we'll work on that let's go to
no still can't hear y'all
let's go to james
and then we'll try coming back to yvonne
james
james james is next let's get james up
with us
james i can hear you go ahead my friend
hey doc
yes sir started uh taking your advice
and the mineral
back in the 80s
wow the i started taking the minerals
back in the 80s when it was uh body
toddy from soaring eagle
been taking it ever since
and i'm 68 now just retired
and i'm in fabulous health i've always
been in fabulous health my kids take the
teddy
my wife took it through all her
pregnancies and
we're all in super good health here but
recently since i just retired i'm not as
active as i used to be and to be honest
with you until i started listening to
you regularly on coast i didn't really
take what i was taking by weight i just
took what it said on the bottle not
realizing that i should be taking twice
as much but
it's uh
held me up good until now but since i
retired i'm starting to get trigger
finger i think they call it in one
finger on my left hand and it it only
starts in the evening after dinner if
i'm sitting watching television if i
make a fist and clench it and then try
to open it up there's one finger that
doesn't want to open up all the way
uh
[Music]
middle finger
a little far okay and it's it's like
that all night and in the morning when i
get up and shower it goes completely
away for the rest of the day it's just
okay how much do you weigh what's your
body weight what's your money baby
what's your body weight james
200 i'm five nine
okay so that's about right okay
okay maybe a few pounds overweight but
just a few
all right and so
uh any other things going any high with
pressure diabetes any arthritis and a
knee or a hip or
okay how many times a night do you get
up to your neck
uh sometimes never okay if it depends if
i drinks a lot too late in the evening
i'll have to get up once in the middle
of the night but okay
at it all
okay good
all right
um well trigger finger
is a nerve thing okay it's caused by the
skull squeezing the spinal cord
and um it's not necessarily going to be
equal on the right and left side so you
can have trigger finger on one hand and
not on the other hand
okay
and um
this is is because the hole that the
spinal cord comes through because the
spinal cord is made in the brain comes
out of this big hole which is for in
latin foramen magnum which is latin for
big hole okay
and um
the
pressure is put on the spinal cord
and the spinal cord
then
uh sends messages out you may get
tremors you ever get trimmers
shakes or trimmers anything like that
okay good
but um
all right and so yeah and you can
begin to get these problems in your
fingers and your hands and your wrists
and say oh you have carpal tunnel
syndrome you have trigger finger and all
kind of stuff it's really the skull
squeezing the spinal cord
okay so
you want to make sure that you're taking
at um 200 pounds i want you to and again
you may be doing this but this is for
our listening audience you need to get
rid of all the bad foods no fried foods
no processed meats no oils no glutens no
wheat no brown rice notes no sugar no
carbonated drinks and when i say no
fried foods i mean no air frying no deep
frying no pan frying no frying of any
kind
and then no carbohydrate drinks even the
diet one's got to go because the
carbonation neutralizes stomach acid so
you cannot efficiently absorb minerals
and digest food
then
um i also
um want you
uh to take two healthy brain and heart
packs per month there's one per hundred
pounds of body weight you weigh 200
pounds it's easy math uh two healthy
brain and heart packs you want to full
dose everything twice a day
i want you to take two bottles a month
of our msm so you take three at
breakfast three at dinner three at
lunchtime and they're gonna support and
promote maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae bone makes
your bone itself bone marrow
okay very important here
so that those holes open up and take the
pressure off the nerves and the spinal
cord
and then i also want you to have our
collagen peptides take a scoop of that
in your breakfast drink in the morning
and a scoop of that in your evening uh
drink
uh the collard peptides then vitamin d
three three of those twice a day
okay
and then um let's see here
um
i think
that's where
we want to go
um um and also if you want to
uh you could throw in
um
something like the beyond osteofx a
scoop of that in your morning drink and
scoop with that in your evening drink
um
that's going to speed up the process
and then you know call us every couple
of weeks because people want to hear
because this is not an uncommon
situation you have
and of course it could be a thousand
times worse if you weren't taking
the the program you were taking but it
needs to be tweaked a little bit
okay and uh yes and we can get rid of
these
sort of negative things happening okay
okay it sounds good thank you very much
doc well thank you for sharing
thank you james
well dr wilick i have a lot of people
ask me
what are the different ways that you can
take the tangy tangerine
one of my favorite ways
is i will mix it in plain greek full fat
yogurt
i'll do half a scoop
mix it up in there
and i just absolutely love the taste and
i'll do that with my breakfast
so there's an option for some of you
well you can do the tangy tangerine and
i like to do half doses so it's not
quite so sweet and i do my other half in
in my water and shake it up
and you can do the half a scoop of tangy
tangerine half a scoop of osteo fx a
full scoop of collagen peptides because
there's no flavor to that and you get
all of that wonderful collagen from five
different types of collagen mix it up
and have that as part of your breakfast
okay very very good sound
okay it sounds very good
awesome
now i have a question coming in and they
want to know are there any approved
bottled oils
no even if it's organic
no
if you want an oil what you want to do
is uh you know eat the beans
you know just
bake or boil some beans if you want to
you can eat um go pull olives off the
tree and eat them right off the tree
but you don't want the olive oil ex
squeezed out of the out of the
out of the olive and sitting on the
shelf in a grocery store for two months
heating up and oxidizing and all that
kind of stuff okay so turn something
that is it actually has some required
nutrients in it
okay the efas and the f8 pluses
or prevent blood clots and that kind of
stuff
it's very very important to do those
things
um
so some of some other ways to find your
efas we're talking essential fatty acids
that's correct fish liver especially
fish livers okay also
um
it's one of those things where
i want to make sure
that you're not doing something bad for
instance with something good don't do
something bad with something good
people say yeah it's more convenient i
just take the btt
2.0 tablets i don't take the powder well
the powder is vitamins and minerals the
tablets are designed to support the
immune system
and also to be an anti-inflammatory pain
reliever okay it doesn't have all the
nutrients it's not designed to be a
replacement for the powder so somehow
some people get that confused because
they don't read the label they just look
at the title on the label oh it's the
same title as the powder so it must be
the same no it's not
okay the the tablets are to support the
immune system
and to be anti-inflammatory reduced pain
or relieving inflammation
whereas the the powder has 215 nutrients
in it
okay which is designed to provide the
nutrients necessary for all your
biochemistry to work for every organ in
the body
two totally different things so they're
not interchangeable i take them both i
take them both i take them both i do as
well and those tangy tangerine tablets
folks if you're familiar with auric
scores
tangy tangerine tablets have 160
as their auric score
on the tangy tangerine i believe it's 8
400.
so you're looking at a huge difference
when it comes to antioxidants
that work on kicking those free radicals
out of your body
yeah if you have something serious you
have free radical damage you have cancer
you have stuff like that
uh you want to be taking those tablets
okay that's but that's in addition to
the powder
okay that's in addition to the held
abandoned heart pack not as a
replacement not interchangeable
all right let's try going to vaughn
again vaughn go ahead and unmute let's
see if we've got you connected
did it work yes did it oh it did praise
god
good morning dr wally good morning thank
you
thank you for everything but i have a
question i asked you no you don't look
like a vaughn you don't look like a
vaughn i am 63.
i'm trying to hit you is your name
vaughn or vonnet it's it's manzilla
i'm sorry
von zella z-e-i-a
vandella okay yeah so we cut it off and
say bond
oh bon okay we're thinking
okay
okay yeah
now i'm 165 pounds
uh which is overweight i already know
but
uh i've been on the products for two
months
but i have a question to ask you
uh i switch from 2.0 to the 2.5
and all of a sudden one idea is that
because you know being gluten-free the
diet everything is the same
but i started and i you know you said
put three msm's in your drink so i do it
like every drink that i drink because i
drink uh the tangie tendering all day
i'm kind of like broke out i used to be
allergic to suffer
so
the whole body
but the diet is healthy
i still drink it so i'm going like well
maybe my body will overcome whatever
it's going through
okay well if you're taking three
um
of the msm
how many times a day three four five
it'll be four or five how many yeah
because i drink the liquid all day okay
well here's what i want you to do is cut
it back at 165 pounds i want you to cut
it back to take two three times a day
okay okay
everything else stay the same usually
it's on schedule but that was the only
difference because when i was at the the
two the 2.0 i used to put the the three
i what is it msm you just put them in
the bottle and drink it no problems but
i went to the 2.5 and i was going like
it i got a reaction from the 2.5 so i
was going like am i
well you have two choices you can have
two choices you go back to the 2.0 or
you can stay on the 2.5 and cut your msm
in half
okay
okay got it now let me ask you the last
question i have to ask you um
you know
we're all up in age uh my question is
you know the tooth decay uh if we got
implants i know it affects our skeletal
system
what's your thought on tooth decay in
the implants
okay well first of all you have to
appreciate
that your jaw and your upper dental
arcade or the upper teeth is all part of
your skull right
so what's going on in your jaw
represents what's going on in your skull
right
what's going on in the skull represents
what's going on in your jaw
uh did you have braces when you're a
teenager did you go to an orthodontist
no no okay good did you ever have
receding gums or bleeding gums
the bleeding gums because uh you know
they were bleeding until i started
taking your product okay good okay so
basically when you have bleeding gums
this means that the bone underneath is
not happy and healthy
okay your gums are
there's two things happening number one
the blood vessels supporting the blood
supply to the teeth are being pinched
and so they're bleeding another thing is
they're being pinched
and the bones underneath them are not
doing real well
okay because they're not getting the
nutrition
and so again
all those symptoms will go away
when you get off all the bad foods you
take the
the big hammer
okay the two healthy random heart packs
at 165 pounds about two healthy brain
heart packs
a month full dose everything twice a day
except for the msm you want to take
three three um
twice a day or two three times a day how
are you going to do it okay
okay
keep in touch
i will i love it thank you okay thank
you bond
all right thank you godzilla
so glad to have you on
dr wallach let's let's see we've got
about nine minutes before
um we take a break
so let's go to one of the email
questions that came in
and danny says i was diagnosed with
stage four kidney failure
would like to know if there's anything i
can do to slow the progression
now danny didn't give a weight but let's
go for say 200 pounds dr wallach
what would you recommend for somebody
200 pounds who
is experiencing stage four kidney
failure now i know there's a lot of
questions that you would have for
for this individual
um but with kidney failure
most of the time it's safe to consume
there's also some blood pressure issues
that's correct
okay when you have kidney failure it's
really a matter of the arteries in the
kidney damaged
okay and they're not getting sufficient
blood supply to the kidneys so it can do
its job of filtering
okay that's the short version of what's
going on there
and so um let's see here we don't have a
weight for danny do we so let's just say
um well you said 200 pounds okay i got
it in case 200 pounds all right
i need to
take a two healthy brain and heart packs
from none of the bad foods again
no fried foods no processed meats no
oils no glutens no wheat no bar right
now so sugar no carbonated drinks even
that one's got to go and no fried foods
means no air frying no pan frying no
deep frying okay
no frying and then
um
we want this danny to take two healthy
brained heart packs a month a full low
setting twice a day two bottles a month
to the mnsm so you can take three at
breakfast street lunch with dinner time
to support and promote maintenance
repair cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue including the walls of
the arteries and walls of the vein that
go to the brain the heart and the
kidneys
and then um we need to have the ultimate
daily classic tablets the ultimate daily
classic tablets i'd have them take three
i i'd go for three three times a day
it'll be
two bottles a month i think you can
scrape up three three times a day out of
two bottles a month of the of the
ultimate daily classic tablets and
they're going to support healthy blood
flow through blocked arteries in the
brain and the heart and the kidneys
they'll also support
healthy blood pressure
and so
usually we take people that haven't
urinated in 10 years they're on dialysis
say six days a week and in two weeks
time on our program they're urinating so
they drop the dialysis to three days a
week and then two more weeks are totally
off the dialysis
uh
the kidney responds very well when you
do everything right
and so this
should respond very
very um which i say
uh predictably because we do this so
often throughout the world
um and so it just works like a charm
okay
thank you so much dr wallach and we've
got six minutes let's go to deborah who
has her hand up
deborah go ahead unmute yourself
hi dr wallach
hi
uh
i've got a friend that don't have a lot
of information about her all i know is
that she's had a stroke
and uh she has still has a right-sided
weakness unable to really use that arm
and leg is that much and so what would
you suggest for her
okay do you have a weight or should we
just go buy 100 pounds of body weight i
just go by a hundred pounds i don't have
a weight
okay so
uh basically she needs to get rid of all
the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meats no oils no glutens no
eating about ryan oh so sugar no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go
i wanted to have per 100 pounds of body
weight one healthy brain and heart pack
per month if she weighs
um
more than 100 pounds like 120 or
something like that get an extra bottle
of water sleeping with the five
cofactors so you take three of those
twice a day or two three times a day for
a total of six a day of our selenium
with the five cofactors because one
bottle comes with the healthy branded
heart pack
then i also want her to have
the msm
three of those twice a day per 100
pounds of body weight
and they're going to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between a vertebrae
um
including the walls of arteries and
veins
and then um let's see here collagen
peptides a scoop of that in the morning
drink a scoop of that an evening drink
again it'll support and promote the
immune system and the bone marrow but
also in maintenance of the connective
tissue in the walls of the arteries
and the
the um
veins
and then uh let's see here
i do
um
want um deborah to have let's see here
um i'm gonna need three three of those
twice today it's two bottles a month so
absorb stuff and put them in the right
place now the minerals in the correct
place
and
um
there's two types of strokes one is a
hemorrhagic stroke where the blood
vessel burst might even have a small
aneurysm and burst and so it's a
bleeding into the brain
the other type of stroke is a blood clot
in a vein or an artery
okay
so in either case
this program
is going to
deal with both of those
okay
because you get the efas the fa pluses
and the health brand heart pack
and you get the
um connective tissue supporting
materials in the msm
and in the collagen peptides and
and so forth so this is going to be a
very easy thing but it does take some
time
to repair now if she does have
mental symptoms
okay instead of just pain or dizziness
or lightheadedness if she has
um
kind of uh symptoms associated with that
um so you know go ahead and take
the uh um let's see here memory fx three
of those twice a day uh also the
synaptic take three of those twice a day
and also the de-stress capsules take
three of those twice a day and that's
going to give the brain what it needs
except for one more thing
um they need
three eggs twice a day with soft yolks
they need the cholesterol to rebuild the
myelin which is the white matter of the
brain
and also the spinal cord
and it heals very quickly when you're
eating the eggs with soft yolks we're
talking about soft boiled soft yo soft
poached soft yolk soft soft scrambling
butter
and
um hard-boiled eggs won't count
and um because it destroys
the cholesterol which is what you want
here to help her rebuild
the white matter of the brain okay
and also the walls of the of the blood
vessels
okay
all right thank you dr wallach
you bet
awesome thank you deborah
and so dr wilick i'd like to mention a
couple of those things that you had said
that after a stroke can affect the brain
and that could be slurred speech delayed
speech inability to speak
in addition to
not having movement or limited movement
with paralysis on either side of the
body right drooping of the face all
those things and a lot of tremors a lot
of you know the people that get a lot of
this tremor stuff
yeah so there's a lot of things to
to look for folks when it comes to the
effects of
what initially
is because of poor diet
not getting the nutrients that the body
needs in order to actually thrive
because
the the rda recommended daily allowance
that's barely surviving
barely side surviving amounts and then
some of those things they don't have
amounts for at all
and just because
it says
fda approved does not mean
it's beneficial to our body
i just and and jaunty's probably gonna
yeah well
when they say fda approved their primary
goal was to make sure it wasn't going to
kill you
that's right
well let's go let's go above and beyond
because we are over achievers dr wallach
and let's give our body what it actually
needs well there you go and right now
we need a five-minute break
so everybody we will be right back with
ask doc live
go ahead and get up and stretch
and make sure that you have
your cup
full of something to drink because we
want to stay hydrated we are getting
into those summer months where it is
warming up and the body needs extra
fluids if you have plant dry minerals
throw on a splash of plant derived
minerals you can't get enough minerals
folks
the body absorbs it all the way through
the system
and every single part of your body
needs trace minerals we will be right
back on ask doc live
don't go away
hello and we are back on ask live thank
you so much everybody for joining us
today
i really do truly hope that you are
receiving some information that is
empowering to you
that you can utilize
i mean
we have so many different options even
if you have specific allergies to
different things
that allergy is actually
because of a compromised digestive
system working on the digestive system
and getting the bacteria right healing
that lining getting that gluten out of
the system and allowing that villi that
goes like a shag rug all throughout the
digestive system allowing that to
breathe and absorb and not be coated
anymore
is going to get you in
not just baby steps but huge steps
towards achieving optimal health and
that includes eliminating
food allergies
and the only reason why i say that is
because i did it myself
food allergies were something that i
thought that i had that i was going to
live with
all of my life
and now i have been able to eat anything
i want and when i say anything i want
that does not include
bread
and all those different things that were
negatively affecting my health before
so getting my digestive system
straight and functioning properly and
getting all of these nutrients into the
body and absorbed deep into the cells is
what has given me my life back and
dr walick
welcome back to
live can you hear me
i can hear you fabulously
okay
all right well let's go to the next
question that was emailed in dr wallach
and lydia says i have been having pain
in my knees i'm thinking it might be
from bad cartilage
is there anything that i can take some
kind of protein eat more protein or what
are your recommendations so lydia is 67
years old she's 125 pounds at five foot
four
what would you recommend for lydia dr
wallach
okay
when you have knee pain it's definitely
a deficiency
okay and uh it indicates what's going on
in every joint in your body and it's
cleaning your skull
your hips your knees your ankles your
shoulders your wrists your vertebrae and
your back your jaw everything is in in
the same dilemma
okay
and so the first thing you have to do is
get rid of all the bad stuff no fried
foods no processed meats no oils no
glutens no wheat nobody right now so
sugar no carbonated drinks
you know the diet one's got to go when i
say no fried foods it means no air
frying no deep frying no pan frying no
frying whatsoever
and then
um at 125 pounds
i would go with one healthy brain and
heart pack per month get another bottle
of arthelene with the five cofactors
there's one bottle of arsenic with the
five cofactors in the health abandoned
heart pack
so you can um take three of those twice
a day or two three times a day for a
total of six a day and then you need
uh because you have a knee problem i'd
go with two bottles a month of our msm
so you can take three at breakfast
through lunch for dinner time they're
gonna support and promote maintenance
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between a
vertebrae bone breaks the bone itself
including the knees and the hips and the
wrists and the elbows and the shoulders
and the
vertebrae and ankles and so on
and then you also need the beyond osteo
fx take a scoop of that with your
breakfast drink a stupid eating drink
don't forget the collagen peptides you
scoop with that with a breakfast drink
and a scoop of that with your
uh evening drink vitamin d3 take three
of those twice a day that's two bottles
a month so you can absorb the minerals
and put them in all the right places
and if you have really restrictive pain
we do have the cm cream you can put four
or five drops of our trum oil
from our aromatherapy oil division you
can put the four or five drops of the
trum oil and like a teaspoon of our same
cream put that on the knee and within
minutes you'll get significant pain
relief and that will last for say two
hours or so
and um usually within a week or so you
won't even need the same cream in the
trum oil okay because once you begin to
repair things the discomfort the
swelling the pain all go away
so
uh you're not alone lydia this is a very
common thing and that's because our
foods do not have everything we need i
don't care how well you eat i don't care
if you're spending a lot of money on
food
um uh some foods are a negative okay and
so you really have to watch it and so
here's where i you know
um would be sure to
um
uh you know
go online uh um rebecca's gonna give you
websites and stuff like that so you can
get a hold of our books
and um
cds and dvds so that you can get
information
which is going to help you understand
why you have to make these changes in
your diet
okay over to you rebecca
all right thank you dr wallach and yes
if you are interested in any of dr
wallach's books we have the most popular
ones at
askdoclive.com
if you're looking at the cds and some of
the
well
doctor well like i've been looking at
your website the last few days and there
is
so many options
i had somebody yesterday want one of
everything
it was pretty pretty cool because then i
was able to get in there and really take
a look at what you've done over decades
dr wellick we have some of your earliest
lectures on
cd on dvd
and the message is still the same
yeah the truth then is still the truth
now
that's right
so
drjwalik.com if you're interested in
seeing all of the publications that dr
wallach has available
for you to be able to obtain and
i'm amazed at how affordable they are as
well dr wallach which which is fantastic
you want to make sure that people get
the information
and for people that are wanting to get
these as gifts or if you're in the
youngevity business and you want to
provide these as incentives or you know
just kind of a
congratulations for reaching goals you
can buy multiple copies and receive huge
discounts on orders of 10 or more and
that expenditure is tax deductible
because it's
growing your business
and so forth
and it's totally designed to be
compatible with everything that
younggivity does
yeah absolutely i love it
well everyone thank you so much for
joining us on askdoc live we are not
done yet we've got another 50 minutes
and if you're on live with us and would
like to ask a question of dr wallach
find that option in the zoom menu on
raising your hand get your hand raised
let's get your questions answered
we are going to go to the next question
that we have dr wallach
and
dorothy would like to know what to do
for nerve pain from spinal stenosis of
the neck
so
we're gonna go by per hundred pounds on
this one dr walt okay
okay
spinal stenosis of the neck
and the nerve pain associated with it
yeah well there you go
well again the spinal cord comes out of
the the skull through the foramen magnum
the big hole which is latin for big hole
the spinal cord is made in the brain
most people don't realize that they
think the spinal cord is made in the
spinal cord but no it's actually made in
the brain comes out through the back of
the skull
down the back
and wherever there's a vertebrae and a
disc if the disc
shrinks the vertebrae get closer
together they begin to pinch the spinal
cord and some of the nerves that are
coming out the sciatic nerves coming out
of the spinal cord
and they get all kinds of symptoms okay
including
um
terrible neck pain of course when they
lay down at night the
posture puts pressure on that joint
um
i think there's like eight joints in the
neck
okay because of all the various
vertebrae and and so forth and that and
the foramen magnum squeezing that spinal
cord
and it causes all kinds of symptoms
downstream in your shoulders your elbows
um in your wrists and your fingers and
your back
makes you get up at night to urinate
because those nerves are being squeezed
to control the bladder for both males
and females and then also
things happen in the hips and the knees
and can be
coming from what's going on in your neck
okay and most people don't realize this
many doctors don't realize this even
some chiropractors who should know uh
don't realize this
okay
and so basically and we didn't get a
weight so we're gonna go by a hundred
pounds is that correct that is correct
okay so dorothy you need to get rid of
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed meat no oils no gluten so
wheat no butter i know no sugar no
carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go
and then
let's say per 100 pounds of body weight
i want you to have one healthy brain and
heart pack per month once you get if you
only weigh 110 pounds or less i want you
to get um another bottle of arthelene
with five cofactors and take three of
those twice a day
then you
need per 100 pounds of body weight one
bottle of msm so you can take three
twice a day per hundred pounds of body
weight and they're gonna support and
promote mains repair cartilage ligaments
tendons connective tissue including the
walls of arteries and veins and
um
bone marrow and and so forth where you
make your white blood cells your red
blood cells and platelets and so on
and then um let's see here and also
rebuild the the disc between the
vertebrae and keep the vertebrae from
getting closer together and smash in the
nerves okay and that's what's caused
called spinal stenosis
and so that is just sort of like
osteoporosis of your spinal
joints okay from
the vertebrae and the disc between the
vertebrae but it can all grow back very
quickly okay but just taking a pain
reliever you'll get pain relief but the
disease keeps getting worse and worse
and worse at first and finally you
submit the surgery and then you have a
mess and so on
and so you really
want to get on these nutrients as we've
laid out here
and call us every couple of weeks
because you're going to have a great
story dorothy okay
you're going to have a great story but
if you want some pain relief again you
can use our sam cream with uh
say a teaspoon of cm cream on your neck
um
over the place where the pain starts
and um
obviously in addition to the same cream
i would put say four or five drops of
the um
let's see here
um
you see here oh trum oil there you go
trum oil
okay you need the trum oil four or five
drops in the same cream and that will
get rid of pain for um
a couple of hours
okay
all right thank you so much dr wallach
for that i know dorothy's going to thank
you as well
let's you touched a little bit about it
on in the monologue today
diabetes
let's talk a little deeper about
and with diabetes and blood sugar issues
there are pharmaceuticals that are
commonly recommended for
for addressing those conditions can we
really go deep into what is the
underlying cause of diabetes and what
band-aids these pharmaceuticals might be
doing
okay if i really really wanted to be
skeptical
and a bad boy
i would say
the the the
biggest problem associated with diabetes
is the 342 billion dollars we spend
every year to treat the symptoms of
diabetes
because at 342 billion dollars goes to
the doctors
now that's just to treat the symptoms
and so they know they're going to get
their 342 billion again next year
that way they can plan
you know
[Music]
how to get the college money for their
kids tuition how to pay their mortgage
and get their vacation in cabo and all
that kind of stuff right
and so um
type 2 diabetes which makes up 90 of the
diabetic population
is very simple nutritional deficiencies
we have the healthy blood sugar pack
okay if that's your only problems
diabetes which it usually isn't but we
have the healthy
blood sugar pack which is our healthy
start pack with the sweeties added to it
okay
and
don't cold turkey off your medication
but as blood sugar begins to drop you
can slowly reduce medication based on
the numbers
and this is one of those things where
there should be no type of diabetes
because everybody should be taking these
nutrients as a
preventative you know everybody's big on
taking
vaccinations to prevent
some
viruses and all that kind of stuff
infections
but they don't think about preventing
diabetes and arthritis and alzheimer's
disease and heart disease and obesity
and hybrid pressure and ms and
asthma and the need for dialysis and all
kind of stuff they don't think about
preventing those things
okay well if i get a problem with those
insurance will pay for the medication or
the therapy
okay well that's everybody's choice i
suppose
but um
it's one of those things where
type 1 diabetes is a birth defect it is
not
due to a genetic birth defect mama was
missing stuff
when the um beta cells are being formed
in the in the islets of langerhan and
the pancreas
and you should have like six thousand of
those
um
six thousand of those beta cells and
every one of those islets are langerhand
but what if you only have six instead of
six thousand you only have six
okay well then you're going to have type
one diabetes
and invariably most doctors when your a
kid is born with diabetes and they take
the blood sample from
from the umbilical cord because they
make a lot of money from type 1 diabetes
okay
and so
they put them on when they find their
diabetic they put them on
the
um metformin okay which is an oral form
of insulin
and it doesn't work they come back their
blood sugar is worse than everything
okay you have a genetic form of diabetes
we're just going to go ahead and trace
you got to come in every month so we can
monitor it and so on blah blah blah
well under those circumstances the
doctor has
a
patient for life
okay
but
if the mother's getting all the
nutrition
she needs and the embryo would need say
for six months to a year before
pregnancy
and then there's not gonna be any more
type one diabetes
okay but when when women go to the obgyn
say you know i miss two periods i think
i may be pregnant
and he does a pregnancy test sure enough
she's pregnant well it's too late the
baby's already got
all these problems
were based on
you know not having all those nutrients
and optimal amounts and so the baby can
be born with type
1 diabetes um
herb's palsies
um and see here things like
um
osteoporosis of skull
down syndrome
you name it okay all this stuff it just
drives you crazy they're totally
preventable
so dr wellick john has a question um
that's related to this and he is six
foot 160 pounds so he's tall and then
56 years old he's been having a hard
time getting his a1c in range
what would be your full recommendation
for somebody who is dealing with blood
sugar issues
okay
now well this is something it's very
easy you go to a pharmacy without a
prescription
and you can get these test strips you
can pee on and see if you have sugar in
your urine you can get the test strips
where you stick your finger and get
those little
um
lancets they call them stick your finger
get a drop of blood and use those
uh test strips and they only cost like a
buck 50 a piece
you don't have to go sit in the doctor's
waiting room and get covered okay we're
sitting in the waiting room um and so
forth and you don't have to pay a
hundred bucks for a visit you'll pay you
can get a bottle of three it costs you
five bucks
okay
and you can test it yourself
you can manage your own diabetes you can
test it see how you know if you're under
control or not under control or so forth
okay
and so
um basically
um at 160 pounds
uh this guy needs to i'm assuming it's a
guy is that correct
yes john okay john okay
right and so at 160 pounds i would have
john take two healthy brain and heart
packs from none of the bad foods of
course no fried foods no processed meat
so oils of gluten no wheat bread right
now no sugar no carbonated drinks
but two healthy brained heart packs per
month full dose of them twice a day
i want them to take two bottles a month
for msm's and take three at breakfast
field industry dinner time
and um then i also wanted to have
um let's see here a scoop of our
collagen peptides a breakfast drink and
scoop at our dinner drink that's one of
the large canisters of collagen peptides
vitamin d3 three of those twice a day
that's two battles a month
okay
and then
uh for for the um
diabetes to get things under control
um get the a1
c down to five or so well certainly
below six you know like 5.7 or 5.3 that
kind of stuff you don't want it at 14.
okay your a1c tells you whether you're
managing your diabetes correctly or not
um
but here's where you want to also add
the sweeties go ahead and take three of
those twice a day per hundred pounds of
body weight
and it's made two bottles a month
because they're small bottles
and
um
as your blood sugar drops
you can slowly reduce your medication
don't call turkey after medication you
can slowly reduce medication for
diabetes uh based on the numbers usually
within anywhere from two to four to six
weeks you'll be an ex-diabetic
except if you're a type one you might go
from
an
a1c of eight
you probably get it down to say
six or six point five or something like
that you won't get it down to five
because there's still a lot of struggle
going on there because
don't have enough of those beta cells to
make enough insulin to do everything
correctly
okay
all right thank you so much dr wallick
for that
i have lots of questions in regards to
blood sugar so that
will answer many questions that we'll be
able to use this video and share with
others
to help them know exactly what they need
to do
in order to take control of their health
and dr wellick one thing that i really
appreciate you for is
not telling people this cold turkey off
their pharmaceuticals you don't want to
do that folks you want to make sure that
you are monitoring at home just as dr
wallach mentioned whatever it is that
you're taking that pharmaceutical for
and work with your doctors to reduce it
until you no longer need it
because the body is getting what it
needs in order to function the way it
was divinely created
so
will you get an a plus
i like a pluses i might even go back to
school but
who knows
the next question that i have dr wallach
is how about age spots like age spots on
the face thankfully
i don't have them anymore but what would
you recommend for somebody that is
dealing with age spots
okay age spots are oxidative damage
to the
cells in the skin
usually you know the um the glands in
the skin that produce the oils that keep
the skin
healthy and happy and so forth
and so there's a lot going on there when
you have age spots they're an indication
that something's not right with the
physiology of your skin usually a
nutritional deficiency
so they need to get rid of all the bad
foods they need to
take the 90th century nutrients better
yet since there's a potential danger
there of a stroke or something i would
go with the healthy brain and heart pack
one per hundred pounds of body weight
i would also take the msm
i would take the
collagen peptides
all for the health of the skin
and then we have another one
it's a secret sauce for her skin
it's it's called hair skin and nails
okay hair skin and nails go ahead and
take three of those twice a day for a
hundred pounds of body weight
and
the uh a spots begin to go away and they
will stay away as long as you stay away
from the bad foods because it's a
combination of not having the nutrients
to protect you
and doing bad stuff like eating fried
foods and
eating
gluten and drinking carbonated drinks
those kind of things they contribute
significantly to the formation of age
spots
all right thank you so much dr wellick
and something that just came out that
i'm super excited about in fact i'm
picking up mine today is we now have a
collagen bundle
that is a topical for the skin
so you've got two parts there one of us
is a
collagen cream that you apply on top and
another part of it is a hyaluronic acid
which helps to ex to defoliate and and
hydrate the skin so i'm really excited
about that bundle so get with the person
that
recommended this program to you and ask
them about how you also can get your own
bundle for the skin
and the nutrients because you know
whatever we do on the skin is only skin
deep we want to work from the inside out
and giving our body all those nutrients
yeah because the skin is kind of like a
barometer
what's going on in your skin is going on
in your heart and your brain and your
liver and your lungs and stuff and your
skin stuff won't kill you
but the same stuff that's damaging the
skin that damages your liver and your
heart and your lungs your brain will
kill you that's right so yeah you want
to pay attention to those details those
are red warning lights
and there are so many red warning lights
folks
we actually have a cd yeah we actually
have a cd called the red warning lights
goes into eight or nine of the ones that
are you know red warning lights for
really really serious dangerous
deficiencies
well and let's talk about some of the
worst red warning lights dr wallach that
people just ignore
okay
i think some of them they
ignore is dry skin
cracked skin that kind of stuff because
the same thing's happening to your
arteries your veins on the inside
okay that's one
and then
another one is constipation and diarrhea
oh yeah you know everybody my family's
got constipation so i figure it's just a
genetic thing no
uh you're eating gluten
and so you've killed all the villi in
your intestines so instead of your
intestines looking like a shag rug and
all that
valuable
surface area to absorb nutrition
suddenly now your intestines look like a
plastic tube you've lost 90 of your
absorptive surface
and so
when you have constipation or diarrhea
you've got big trouble coming not maybe
tomorrow not maybe next week not maybe
in a month but in four months six months
eight months a year you're in big
trouble
so everybody don't ignore those red
warning lights
especially that dry skin i mean so many
times people think of oh dry skin it's
just because it's winter now
or it's summer now
well
no that dry skin can happen anytime and
it's because the body is missing things
from the inside that is not getting and
it is just telling you hey pay attention
don't ignore me
you know our bodies if if we don't have
our bodies what do we have folks we have
nothing
and as we get older but let's enjoy life
let's
let's be able to cherish those moments
and
not just for ourselves but for our
families and our communities
also share this information with people
you love people you know people that you
are acquaintances with who
are struggling with health
is now that you have information you are
empowered
to be able to share it with other people
and i invite you to do so
so dr wallach
we have about 30 more minutes here
and i want to encourage anybody if you
have any questions
and you're online with us
raise your hand i have tons of questions
from emails but i absolutely love being
able to get people on with us live
and talk with them and interact with
them and have that real personal touch
that you give so
here's something that i've been
wondering about
okay
and this is something you personally
have experience with
and i know we've touched on it in the
past and that has to do
with children
and behavioral issues
what we now have as labels of add
adhd
autism
i mean there's so many different
labels dr wallach
please share with us once again
your experience
and folks this is this is something that
is such an encouragement to me
because whenever we see a kiddo that's
having behavioral issues
we're like oh
we automatically think into the future
and all of the bad things that are going
to happen with them
well
this man that we have with us today
has done more good than anyone
i have ever met
in my whole entire life
and they were wanting to
institutionalize him because of behavior
make me cry
so dr wallach take over and share with
us your story
okay thank you so much
for all you do and thank you for
allowing me to share my story
um
let's see here as you said 80d attention
deficit disorder
adhd attention deficit hyperactivity
disorder these are both nutritional
deficience diseases of the central
nervous system the brain and the spinal
cord of kids
and
as you point out i'll jump back to my
early days when i was about four years
old i started having adhd i was actually
very violent and i would just beat up
other kids they just walk by me and
smile and i just punch them kind of
thing um i
was very strong because we lived on a
farm and i'm throwing bales of hay to
the calves and ponies and stuff like
that and carrying bags of feed to the
chickens and so on so i was very strong
and i was very disruptive in church and
in school and
uh anytime we'd go someplace where
there's a lot of people i was disruptive
so they would really have to have a uh
parents on each side of me to keep me
out of trouble
okay
and so by the time i was nine years old
20 doctors had checked me out
20 doctors and this is in the state of
missouri we lived in a little town
called well outside the town of wellston
missouri outside of st louis
and um on a farm
and so
the doctor the pediatrician said okay
look uh
joel has uh got this problem we have 20
of our best doctors look at him they
can't figure it out so we want to put
him into an institution and try and get
him cured
but he can't go home every night he's
gonna have to stay there
and so my parents agreed to that because
they're tired of having to mess with all
my trouble i'm creating
and so
um
it's friday night and i'm sitting on the
edge of my bed like nine o'clock at
night and they're packing up my clothes
and things so on monday they're going to
take me to this institution
well i'm saying to myself well why is it
i have these problems
okay not too many people have these
problems how come i have this problem
and so i'm thinking well
um i'm eating the same thing my mom and
dad
are eating or is eating or eating okay i
i'm
eating the same thing that our animals
are eating that we grow the food on the
property
and they don't have the problems why do
i have the problems
oh
now the animals were giving different
things in addition to what we're eating
we're giving them other stuff
and so the next morning saturday morning
i ran out to the barn i dumped my
oatmeal and my cheerios and
the breakfast of champions wheaties out
to the chickens
and i got the alfalfa pellets were
enriched with vitamins and minerals
and and poured milk on them and had that
for breakfast on saturday morning
sunday morning
monday morning and by monday afternoon
just two and a half days after i started
i'm perfectly cured
now this
i didn't say anything to anybody but it
freaked me out
and so would go to church and people are
whispering and pointing and noticing and
i'm just sitting there
not disrupting anymore
and suddenly now i'm not pushing the
other kids around and kicking them when
they're on the ground and so on
i'm being a pretty nice guy
and so what what maybe they thought it
was on some kind of medication or
something but um
that went on and on and on
and so
um
this this became a big big thing
and to make a long story short
uh i obviously you know went to school
and became i got my degree in
agriculture i got my degree in very
medicine
i
went to
africa worked on the white rhino
conservation project and i had written a
paper on a mast style from pollution and
when i was in africa working on the
white rhino project marlon perkins
mutual omaha kingdom show and dr barry
commenter
from
washington university and barnes
hospital in st louis um used my paper to
get a 25 million dollar grant from nih
to study pollution
okay and diseases
um in zoo animals that would affect
people just kind of like a canary in the
mine in the coal mines so if these zoo
animals began to die
and they would trace it to that nutrient
or that poison um
they could say okay we got to evacuate
the city because the people are in
danger so there's a whole idea of that
study
and that was the beginning and so i
began to deal with all this stuff and of
course many many awards
um the klaus schwartz award from
university of california uh for
my work
with um
muscular dystrophy with jerry lewis and
the telethon you don't hear about that
anymore because we found the cause for
instance and cure plus physique don't
hear about cystic fibrosis anymore
because we found the cause prevention
cure of cystic fibrosis you don't hear
about sudden death syndrome anymore
because as a side benefit
um dr milan and i we went to china we
did one thousand seven hundred autopsies
on kids under the age of ten
okay uh from keyshawn university and
hailing zhong province which is in
northeastern china
and got it published
and got the lifetime achievement award
from the united nations
okay now i'm telling you this not to
brag i'm telling you this because i want
you to know that this
is recognized by scholars
as being
useful correct information
and so this is why we were able to start
youngevity
or 50 years ago
has gone through
many masculinations of different names
and we'd buy other companies and add to
what we're doing and so on
and so we
are continuing to grow we're continuing
to buy other companies and add them to
our ours
and we continue to create new products
based on new data and so forth
and so
um this is not just an overnight thing
this has been
a journey of 75 years
and it's going to be i believe for
another couple hundred years so we're
very excited about that
okay i hope that answers the question
that does thank you so much dr wallach
and i have a lot of people that asked
well why do you have so many products
and you just covered some of that
as we are
going through life and we see a company
that has a wonderful product
and they're struggling
youngevity
brings them in under their wing under
that umbrella
to be able to
allow that product that has so many
benefits in improving people's lives to
continue on
and i mean some of those products we
have a question here in regards to
um
truckers that don't drink coffee
what do we have that help them stay
alert
rebound we've got rebound we have pollen
bursts we have
act we have electro fuel and many of
these products are products that have
been brought in under the umbrella
because of the great benefits that they
offer
that build health
and not just wear it down or
over
stimulate
the adrenals yeah well the the original
concept of energy drinks was to get
caffeine and sugar into people so that
they have energy to
do their work okay if you would but of
course over time that is a negative
because it it leeches the nutrients out
of the tissue and people began to just
live on the sugar and the caffeine and
stay away from good food and don't take
vitamins and minerals and so
ultimately you get a bad outcome
and so um when we came up with um
rebound we actually built that for theo
ratliff our
great basketball player
who lost his position with the atlanta
hawks uh and um and he'd been with many
professional basketball teams over the
years but he lost his position with the
atlanta hawks
um when he was 24 years old now because
he had bone-about arthritis both knees
the currently slipped off one of his
hips so he had arthritis there fractured
his shooting arm wrist and he was
useless to this so the atlanta hawks at
that point said well you know you're a
good basketball player but you're too
fragile to play pro balls so we got to
let you go
so we came up
at 28-24 folks yeah
professional athlete yep
triple a okay and so um we got him on
the rebound we we built that for him we
also came out with our healthy bone and
joint pack we made that for him and
three months time he went back at his
position back
with um
the
atlanta hawks he played for 11 more
years and made a hundred million dollars
in contracts
now he stayed with our program he knew
that's why he got better and so he just
stuck with that program no matter
because a lot of people would be
egotistical and say well i don't need
that stuff anymore i'm doing great here
and then in six months time to a year
later they'd be crashed again but he
stayed with our program
um of the of the rebound and he stayed
with the healthy bone and joint pack
and now he has this big facility this
big property in alabama when she gets
young people who want to be professional
athletes to go there to learn how to
train properly and how to eat properly
and how to take the
nutrients properly and of course all the
stuff that we know are good for in the
healthy bone and joint pack and the
rebound and all that kind of stuff and
so he does this as a payback to
um america so i just really thought that
was great to see a rat live
yeah that's that that is great but he's
actually giving back and he's sharing
what he learned that benefited himself
with others and
i've met theo he's like
seven yeah he's seven foot one
i i felt at five foot seven and a half i
felt like i was two inches tall
um
but just just the nicest kindest hearted
man um i've met
right next to you of course
um
and and something that you mentioned
there is
something that i've really taken to
heart
i had great results
i had the intuition in me to think okay
why am i getting these great results
well
i didn't want to go back to where i was
so i didn't start eating the way i did i
didn't drop
the stuff that i was
that i was doing
because that's what was making me sick
in the first place
well that was part of it
it was not giving my body the nutrients
that it needed in order to be strong
so folks like dr wallach has said many
times when somebody asks them well how
long do i have to take this
as long as you breathe oxygen
as long as you're above ground and not
six foot under
or wherever it is that
you might fall
you need nutrients your body
can't survive
or thrive
without them
so
think about it
you are worth it everybody
invest in yourself it's the greatest
investment that you could
possibly
give to yourself and your future
you are listening to stock live that is
sponsored by
askdoclive.com
again if you were referred to this
program by somebody specific get back
with the person that shared this program
with you
they have their own special way of being
able to get the products to you or they
can refer you to who they get their
products from
we want to make sure that they get to
thank you for sharing this information
with
you
if you have never spoken to anybody
before or you're part of the critical
health news or the astoc live newsletter
and you gained this information from the
newsletter or
our good friend george nori and coast to
coast am
you can answer or do a reply to that
newsletter
we have certified holistic health
coaches that will be able to help you in
getting the information that you need in
order to make sure that your body is
able to
have those raw ingredients to achieve
optimal health
dr wallach let's go to bill who has his
hand up
bill
if you're able to come on camera with us
that would be fabulous if not go ahead
and unmute yourself you are on live with
dr wallach
hi doc wallace this is actually not phil
that does not sound like bill
now this is this is says beyonce and my
name is kathleen
and um i have three things i'd like like
to ask you about doc wallach okay
because i'm not really anxious to go to
see the doctors anymore
okay so the first one is i he had fallen
down and my left knee right around the
kneecap i don't know if this meniscus or
whatever but i heard that and then it
seemed like i got better and that i
heard it again and so now i'm at a point
to where like if you sit down and my leg
is down
uh and i get up it's like i have to kind
of i'll work on a little bit to be able
to put the weight down on it to
straighten it out to walk
once i start walking i'm okay
it's just it doesn't like being straight
down
so that's one thing uh another thing is
i had um cataract surgery about uh just
about a year ago now
and i'm a very nearsighted person and i
was worried about the retina detached
because i don't you know they said when
you have um
when you when you're as nearsighted as i
am that could be a problem well i'm
experiencing right now in my right eye
i'm seeing not like the little things
that you see but like
a long thread no dashes of light or
anything and
um i'm worried about that i don't know
if that's something that'll get better
or not
and then also i have a problem with my
ear where um
after i got a flu shot about five years
ago
uh my ear kind of shut up but never
really opened um and it like opens and
shuts and opens and shuts so i have
those three problems um that maybe you
can okay when you say the ear opens and
such hearing comes and goes
well my right ear it's like it gets
clogged up and then i have to push
around on my ear and then i can open it
up but it doesn't necessarily stay open
all the time
do you ever get do you ever get buzzing
or ringing in the air
um i don't well i do have a noise i
couldn't exactly tell you what it was
not all the time though but if it's real
quiet that's the only time i notice a
noise okay is it a straight noise like a
kind of thing or it is kind of like that
okay yeah that's called tinnitus
okay as okay this causes osteoporosis
skull how old are you
i am i'm gonna be 79 years old next week
yeah okay
79 and you're a lady okay and
how much you weigh i weigh around 161
pounds okay all right i'm about five
four five four and a half by four
something like that
five four okay
okay got it all right
so basically you need to get rid of all
the bad stuff and this is for everybody
else listening and watching as well uh
no fried foods no deep fried no pan
fried no um air fried okay none of that
kind of stuff
no oils of any kind
absolutely no gluten no weaponry and
oats no sugar no carbonated drinks even
the diet one's got to go because
carbonation of the diet drinks still
neutralize stomach acid so you cannot
absorb minerals or digest food
and then
at
161 pounds
i want you to have
uh two healthy brain and heart packs for
months two healthy brain and heart
pattern months a full dose for
everything twice a day and then i want
you to get two bottles a month for msm
so you can take three at breakfast feed
lunch at a time and they're gonna
support and promote mains repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue discs between invertebrate bone
makes the bone itself including the knee
and and ear and so forth and then i need
you to take the collagen peptides take a
scoop of that in your morning drink and
scoop that your evening drink i want you
to take the uh beyond osteo fx take a
scoop of that in your morning drink and
scoop it on your evening drink if you
prefer we do have it also in the liquid
form you could take a half ounce of that
breakfast half ounce of dinner that'd be
a quarter month liquid form
and then i want you to get a vitamin d3
capsule take three of those twice a day
okay
and then do you have any high blood
pressure diabetes issues
no i have nothing like that okay good
all right and so uh let's start there
and for the eye thing you go ahead
and
um i would go ahead with the vision fx
get two bottles of that so you can take
three of those twice today that's going
to help with the eye but the msm and the
collagen peptides are going to help with
the cataract surgery kind of stuff or
cataracts okay also in the walls
arteries the the optic nerve the optic
art the optic vein
um
so the the skull can be squeezing those
and and you might not really have
cataracts you might really just have
osteoporosis skull squeezing the artery
in the vein and the nerves
okay so that's a handsome surgery
i had the surgery for a cataract well
have you ever heard of going to a car
dealership and he says you got something
wrong with your car and he changes apart
he really didn't need to have that done
but he needed the money for tuition for
his kids so he changed the part and got
the bill paid and
you understand what i'm saying i did and
that would be terrible to get that
surgery if you didn't need it yes oh my
goodness okay okay so all things are
possible
okay
uh and so always whenever somebody
recommends surgery you want to go to a
medical school and get a second opinion
the nice thing about medical schools is
they get paid the same regardless of
what the diagnosis is or what the
treatment is okay
okay
okay got it and so in the future in the
future you want to
when somebody says oh you need to have
surgery for that say okay i'm going to
go get a second opinion here i'll be
back to you in a month or so okay okay
so okay so that's how you want to
approach those kind of issues but to
give us a call
um every couple of weeks because you're
going to have some great results here uh
the knee thing will go away very quickly
because that's all connective tissue
stuff and the ear thing might just be
simple connective tissue stuff because
the ear is made up out of cartilage and
connective tissue and that kind of thing
and so but you're getting that tone
and that says you have osteoporosis to
the skull
okay and that cataract you had may not
have been a cataract it just may have
been the skull squeezing the optic nerve
the optic or in the optic vein
and so you may have had two or three
things going on
and you do have that tinnitus you do
have that ringing in the ears which is
an absolute drop dead
um
proof that you have osteoporosis of the
skull
and the line that i'm seeing that's
moving around in my eye that is kind of
long it should not round in circular is
these things gonna at least take care of
that too
well we don't know i haven't seen it
okay and it may be yeah it may be a
light
it may be a light diffraction or it
might be
a piece of connective tissue like a
thread floating around in your eye kind
of like a long thread like floater but i
think it is
that's possible
okay so you know go get you know go to a
medical school in the eye department and
have them have a look at it okay
okay i will do that and then tell us
what they say
okay well thank you very much doc walsh
okay
good to talk with you kathleen okay good
to talk with you too and god bless you
god bless you thank you dear thank you
all right thank you kathleen
and
dr wellick
earlier when we were talking about
collagen and the topical
actually called and thank you nasima
it's actually called the face serum
bundle not the collagen bumble
but face serum bundle
so we have so many products it is
difficult to keep up with them but we
have 5 000 products we just picked up
about three new ones i think
this last week
um
yeah we have some new ones that are
coming out so for those of you who are
looking for
portable
options to put in your water for
minerals we have one coming out that i'm
super excited about
that is that is something to keep your
eye out for
again dr wallach we are coming up to the
top of the hour i can't believe two
hours have passed by
folks we have time for one more question
so if you have a question
that you would like to ask dr wallach
quickly get your hand up
and we will see if we can get you fit in
here
uh dr wallach yes ma'am
let's talk about
options
when you feel that you
financially are not able to afford a
full protocol
okay you have an amazing opportunity
yeah and so basically when you can't
afford the full portfolio with the
basics okay the healthy start pack the
90 essential nutrients you'll save a lot
of money by getting off all the bad
foods bad foods tend to be expensive
and so you want to get rid of all the
bad foods that will save
probably
as much as 10 of your budget your food
budget and then you'll be able to
transfer that over to the supplement
cost okay the vitamin middle cost
and it's one of those things where
you have to have priorities
but getting rid of the bad foods
is going to add
many healthy years to your life it's
going to save you an enormous amount of
unnecessary misery and people notice it
hey what are you doing you're looking
great
and i've never seen you you're usually
sitting there asleep and so forth you're
up you're participating now and all this
kind of stuff are you on some kind of
medication what's going on and so they
will notice that you're different now
when you get rid of all the bad foods
you start taking the 90 essential
nutrients we have
programs for 600 diseases we have 5 000
products we don't expect everybody to
use every one of those thousand products
but some of them are the same we have a
liquid a powder and a pill
of the same product okay
and so it's one of those things where we
have many choices and so on
but you have priorities now if you if
you have limited income you go with the
minimum of the healthy start pack if you
have a little bit more money than that
you can go with the healthy brain and
heart pack which has 215 nutrients
including the 90
okay
and so
that will touch everything
of course the purpose of the
secret sauces is to take more of a
particular nutrient that's going to be
really
uh which i say an accelerator to healing
but if you can't afford that you'll
still get
healing
just with the nutrient level that's in
the healthy start pack and then the
healthy brain and heart pack
but um if you're going to afford
um if you don't say you have five
diseases you can afford one
of the
secret sauces go with the one that's
you know go with the one that the
treatment's expensive or more deadly go
with that one
and
you know it'll be a wise choice
and an even wiser choice dr wallach
is to share this information share these
products with your family your community
help them find the difference which then
puts a thank you check in your pocket
which helps you to
pay for your own supplementation and
have it as a write-off
and there you go for me whenever i
started removing the bad foods from my
diet
and i didn't think they were bad foods
because i didn't buy the sodas i didn't
buy the chips and and the candy
but when i started removing those bad
foods
i did more than 10
savings
on my food
wow
so
i took probably
close to 150
off of my food meal
just by removing those foods that are
found
on the bad foods list the no bottled
oils no wheat barley rye
or wheat and
ryer oats
yes
um
nothing that was fried
nothing that had breading when i started
cooking more at home not doing all those
prepared foods that were just laden with
chemicals like nitrites and nitrates
that are found in processed meats
the budget
or the amount of food that i was
spending
was greatly reduced
or the amount of
money that i was spending on food was
greatly reduced
and that opened up even more room
for me to be able to get the supplements
that i needed
that
supported
my health journey
in a direction that now
i don't have limitations i can roll
myself out of bed
i can go up and down stairs all day long
and enjoy it
instead of having the fear of falling
going up or going down
so folks
we just encourage you to feel the
difference
share this information
with your loved ones with your community
with your
church grandparents
you have or moms and dads you have kids
that are coming up on the age of where
they're looking at or thinking about
getting married and starting their own
families
let's build a healthier world
by not start the supplementation when
you find out you're pregnant but start
before
and let's start removing
those
common things that are now found in
school
that
are getting tagged getting labeled put
in special classes
thrown chemicals at to try to control a
behavior
when
that behavior can be controlled through
supplementation in a more natural way
and the supplements do much more for you
than chemical drugs that suppress this
behavior they do
not not just now at this moment
but in the future too
that then prevents those costly and
expensive
ailments
that end up destroying people's lives
dr wallach we're at the top of our the
hour we are at the end of the show
i think we covered a lot of information
that is going to
really empower
other people
i mean
i wouldn't do this if i hadn't
experienced what i've experienced
and i know our co-hosts nasima omar dr
judy reynolds ruth ellen sanchez she's
coming up here too
and heather bowen
also feel the same way and jonty
mccollier
if it wasn't for finding the truth and
finding that empowerment of what we can
do on our own without having this square
per
prescription
now they just
electronically send it over
you don't need that
take control your own health everyone we
encourage you we invite you
to find again
find and feel the difference get back
with the person that shared this program
with you and thank them and ask them
okay how do i get started
it's not hard
health is simple
media has made it difficult
so dr wallach and my co-hosts i love you
all
thank you so much
we appreciate all of you who are on here
with us
thank you
for being part of our family whether
it's through just taking the products
just taking in the knowledge or actually
as a distributor sharing this
information with others
have a fabulous day and bye for now
thank you so much and love you and your
team
love you dr wallach mwah
i love my team
bye for now